I don't know if you've seen but in this
arrowverse they are bringing back a
bunch of the supermen you're a burden
are you coming back are you putting the
spandex back on at this point in time I
have no news do you want there to be
news would you want to go and do that
well I'm already on the show I have
supergirls father so hard to say how
that would work out but listen I love I
love being part of that whole genre so
III embrace it and if something worked
out that'd be fine you never know what
would it take to get you and Terry back
on screen as Clark and Lois well I'd
love to see that happen I'd love to see
them happy because I think we ended in
the weirdest note ever and so we've
talked about it I'd love to see what
they're doing 25 years later and I'd
love to see that situation I already
started writing little bits and pieces
down so we'll see if I can't convince
somebody to make you know 6 10 12
episode feeling that's an easy sell have
you talked to Terry specifically about
it I had on her thoughts what are her
thoughts on it she agrees that it's a
big great idea I just don't know if we
agree on what should be happening okay
which is perfect for Lois and Clark yeah
that's the exact right vibe and in the
age of reboots and revivals hey somebody
greenlight this give this man a check
why was it important to step out for
this tonight well I work for these guys
I called the Beverly Hills rejuvenation
Center like my own personal Fountain of
Youth they've done some wonderful things
for me personally and I just think
whatever your ailment is whatever issue
you're having they have someone or a
program or something to deal with that
it's really subjective and for me it was
a lot of information I need i hi i
retired from football with a knee injury
as i've gotten older I've had six
surgeries things you started getting
worse worse and it's it's been fantastic
for me so I recommend them all right you
feel younger than ever what's what's
this place providing I'll tell you what
yes I am but for me it's really been the
inflammation and those are the things
getting getting my body working right
there was other things going on with me
and these guys just went through blood
work for mining things and it's again
it's subjective so the things I need it
may not be the things that you'll maybe
not that you need anything I'm looking
at you look very healthy but I mean it
could be whatever and whatever it
happens to be everyone has some other
listen that whole wellness world is a
big giant world and as you get older and
I'm 53 now you start looking at you know
longevity and quality of life and I want
to make sure my quality of life is as
high as can be for as long as can be
[Music]